things change when the Hardy Boys came
to Bridgeport
I've never had friends like the ones I
have now I do anything for them
but if everything you went through
it was all leading up to this
I am a roommate Drew oh I didn't I
didn't think I had a roommate well that
makes two of us
we need to find out about our mom
Chasing Ghosts the only way to figure
that out is to get the map from JB
you guys doing you're a Dapper prom
funny bring our scroll well well well
look at that it's not just a map it's a
schematic
I know what this place is secret
societies secret experiments
Rose grave is a hotbed of mysteries
people we love are in danger
walk away from all of this before one of
you gets hurt or worse
oh
mom wanted to expose the truth
let's finish what she started
no more games
what's wrong
guys this is way bigger than we thought
did you see something I saw your dad
you're out there Beyond any imagination
let's get to it shall we
how you guys feel about daring heists
I'm listening
see you on the other side yeah whatever
[Music]